Let's look at the solution to our distributed last
level cache. We have 16 cores in a four
by four mesh. It doesn't really matter what the
organization of the network is. We need to know that
there are really 16 tiles, numbered 0 through 15,
and that we have an 8-megabyte cache with 256-byte block,
16-way set associative distributed round robin by set. So
set zero will be in slice zero, set one will
be in slice one, etc., and then it just wraps arround. So let's look at
what this address maps to. The least significant
eight bits are telling us what the block
offset is. The next so-many bits are going to
be the index, and the least significant bits
of the index are going to tell us which tile to look at. There are 16 tiles,
so the next digit is really the tile number. And that means
that we go to tile number six. Note that we don't really
need to even compute what exactly is the index because the least
significant bits in this case are telling us what we need to know.